et céline je ris zhi analyste
géopolitique spécialiste du yémen
bonsoir céline cerisy merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france
qu'est ce qu'implique cette décision des
séparatistes du sud du yémen qu'est ce
qu'ils obtiennent en contrepartie pour
renoncer à leurs aspirations
séparatistes
mais bon soir le stc ils ont décidé de
renoncer à leurs à leur première
décision qui était annoncé en avril
dernier au fin mars si mal marée basse
c'est parce qu'ils ont et ils ont été
confrontés à pas mal de problèmes l'un
des problèmes c'est que les promesses
qu'ils ont donné à la population du sud
et surtout à la fondation daniel n'ont
pas donné satisfaction au peuple au
peuple d'un côté aujourd'hui une région
comme la région d'adana est là il
connaît le pire ou les pires moments de
son existence depuis depuis plusieurs
années je ne parle pas seulement de
l'époque de deux tailles abdallah saleh
ou après la révolution au yémen est
aujourd'hui une région comme nadal n'a
plus d'électricité la plus d'eau potable
les salaires n'ont pas été payés est ce
que le stc a promis quand il a décidé
d'avoir cette décision de gestion ou de
ces décisions assez individuelle d'un
côté aujourd'hui ils ont décidé de
revenir à l'accord de ryad qui a été
conclu le 5 novembre 2019
parce que ils ont trouvé vraiment une
solution alternative pour qui leur
permettra non seulement de sauver un peu
la situation mais aussi des jt une
révolution assez le peuple yéménite à
aden ils sont complètement sa voulions à
l'intérieur ya pas de solution il ya une
espèce de clivage des anathèmes
ça se passe très mal donc aussi aussi le
pour le stc aussi les outils il faut pas
les oublier qu'ils essaient vraiment bon
mais justement parce que le yémen c'est
très compliqué c'est une guerre
dans une autre guerre on a l'impression
qu'ils à des conflits qui sont imbriqués
les uns aux autres cette fin des
hostilités entre la coalition saoudienne
et les séparatistes du sud
est ce que ça signifie qu'on va assister
à une intensification de leur lutte
commune contre les rebelles ou outils
soutenu par l'iran
en gros est ce que il vint peut y avoir
qu'une seule guerre dans la région déjà
en fait c'est pas une impression alors
on a plusieurs gares ou yaman ya pas que
les outils et à l'ailé les groupes
extrêmes al qaïda m mais il ya aussi
d'autres groupes que les gens
connaissent pas vraiment et aussi laissé
tribal tout est imbriqué
les choses sont imbriquées les unes dans
les autres et il est très compliqué la
géopolitique du rsi et géopolitiques qui
est compliquée et complexe
aujourd'hui le stc a senti et il sait
très bien que les outils vont pas
s'arrêter à la frontière d'abyane où à
la frontière des tiles ils vont
commencer à avancer sûrement mais
doucement mais sûrement vers le sud
alors je parle d'aden ma part je parle
vraiment je parle de chabwa je parle de
toutes les régions
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont décidé de se
rallier à nouveau au gouvernement
yéménite je parle d'adrien deux
indépendants sur l'a10 et de l'arabie
saoudite ch parle en l'occurrence de 2
de la coalition mais aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas qu'un seul yémen on a plusieurs
yaman le gamin du mouty le yémen la
somalie et de la coalition en à lui y
est mal du spc on a l'oeil est mal d'al
qaïda en alu yaman deux dash
on a des petits ammann qui dépense de
chaque tribu c'est très très compliqué
c'est très imbriquées cette décision
haussier c'est par rapport à le rester
c'est il pense vraiment que le fait de
de se rallier à nouveau apte à pouvoir
sur la digue non seulement il va avoir
des avantages parce que l'accord de
riels a donné un grand avantage au reste
et cdh ont l'air voire 50% de nombre de
gouverneurs 50% de nombre de ministres
50 % du pib certain nombre de biens
certain nombre de 2,2
deux valeurs a ajouté qu'ils allaient se
rajouter à déjà à l'économie assez
affaibli du sud 8e année je parle en
l'occurrence quand je parle le studio
match par lancer à adana pas vraiment
mais aussi l'avantagé le grand avantage
c'est de faire front ou faire face à l'
asset ses démarches des outils dans le
kig essaie de quitter lancement de
quitter mais d'avancer doucement mais
sûrement dans le sud mais à mon avis ça
sera aussi perdu à cause de plusieurs
choses qui il faut pas voir le situation
situation géopolitique on l'a compris tu
es très compliqué au yémen une guerre
qui existe là bas depuis 2015 ce qui est
la coalition saoudiennes et des rebelles
alliées aux rebelles houthi qui a coûté
la vie à au moins 100 milliards ministre
mais comment expliquer qu'il ya un
silence quasi absolu de la communauté
internationale sur cette tragédie
malheureusement le yémen ne s'est pas la
libye assez triste de dire ça mais lui
et moi c'est un pays qui est assez pour
vous je pars en faites pas pour mais qui
est appauvri elle quand même des raisons
internationale il ya des non vie
internationale de faire un silence radio
sur pour que le le le
comment dirais-je que l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats arabes unis qui sont
membres de la coi liette de la coalition
m à ce sont des alliés de l'europe et de
l'occident
et il ya des intérêts il ya vraiment des
rivalités de pouvoir il ya des intérêts
qui se croisent et le lama a été passé à
ces deux grands pays où ces deux grands
c'est un c'est un conflit ce qui n'est
pas seulement régional c'est un conflit
international mais aujourd'hui ça a été
léguée à l'arabie saoudite aux émirats
arabes unis parce qu'ils trouvent leur
intérêt on à la géopolitique de l'eau ou
des espaces maritimes qu'on connaît que
la les émirats exercent et on a aussi le
l'arabie saoudite qui a un prix un pays
qui souhaite garder quand même la
mainmise sur lui et vanessa depuis
toujours c'est pas une nouveauté que
louis émane a toujours été une cause de
de dérangement si je peux appeler ça
comme ça par rapport à l'arabie saoudite
aujourd'hui il n'ya pas le pétrole de
bonne qualité comme en libye
malheureusement aujourd'hui a pas une
proximité géographique je parle de la
géographie naturel je parle pas de la
géographie humaine avec cette zone il ya
aussi des pays d d d d d d pentagone
east ou si je peux appeler ça si je peux
appeler salle et les les acteurs sur
place ce sont des acteurs qu'on veut pas
et 3 c'est sûr qu'on connaissait ses
sauces ya un intérêt pour l'occident qui
vont les arts vivants les strates qui
vont aussi les expertises et ça arrange
toutes les parties sauf le yémen merci
c'est une hérésie d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique et spécialiste du
yémen